fue el 16 de septiembre de 2022 una
joven mujer de 22 años murió luego de
ser arrestada por la policía de la moral
en Teherán que la acusó de usar el velo
de manera inapropiada su nombre
desde entonces se ha convertido en el
símbolo de una protesta sin precedentes
contra el régimen iraní en la primera
línea de esa revuelta estaban las
mujeres que a partir de Entonces
desafiaron a las autoridades cada noche
en todo el país quemando sus velos en
público al grito de mujer vida libertad
a ellas se unieron los estudiantes y
minorías étnicas iraníes
el régimen explica que maxa mini murió
de un infarto y difundió este video en
el que vemos a una joven presentada como
maximini desplomándose frente a la
policía después de meses de represión el
4 de diciembre el gobierno pareció
cambiar de posición disolvió la policía
de la moral Pero tras el efecto del
anuncio aumentan las detenciones en
consecuencias se crea un clima de miedo
las movilizaciones se vuelven cada vez
más discretas la comunidad internacional
condenó enérgicamente la represión de
las autoridades pero sin tomar ninguna
sanción contra Teherán según ongs en
nueve meses las protestas han dejado más
de 500 muertos y han provocado la
detención de varias escenas de miles de
personas las autoridades iraníes también
han ahorcado al menos a siete hombres y
muchos siguen en espera de juicio Este
es el caso de dos periodistas iraníes su
fechoría revelar la muerte bajo custodia
de maxa Mini ellas enfrentan la pena de
muerte